Speaker 1: Hey, you've got to see this. Fox host
Jesse WATTERS tried to confront a satanic temple
leader, Lucian Graves, who we've had on the
program before, and it went really, really,
really poorly. Jesse Waters and others on Fox
News love to go after the Satanic Temple and
the Satanic Temple. You know, some people say
the satanic temple is a satirical religion,
but the truth is it's really no more or
less satirical than any other religion.
And this is sort of the point that you don't
get to say, well, the satanic temple, it's not
like Christianity. No, it actually kind of is.
And so Jesse WATTERS brings on Lucian Graves,
and he seems to think that he's going to
steamroll him and he doesn't. And it's very,
very interesting. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: While we still have some
questions. So let's ask the satanic
temple spokesperson, Lucian Graves.
Speaker 1: First of all, Lucian
Greaves, it's Lucian Graves. It's
not a particularly difficult name to say.
Speaker 3: Lucian, Satan is evil. I thought.
Nice to meet you too. If Satan's evil,
why should kids be in an evil club? Hmm.
Speaker 4: Well, obviously, we don't view
Satan as evil, and it really doesn't matter
to us what your mythology is surrounding
Satan. You need to ask yourself if your
distaste over us identifying as Satan is
is strong enough that you would abandon the
principles of free speech and religious liberty.
Speaker 3: I always thought Satan was like sex,
you know? Like when you're 18, Satan
sex do your thing. But I don't know
if I would want Satan in schools. Do
you understand how parents feel? Right.
Speaker 4: Well, parents can feel that way and
many parents feel similar. We about evangelical
after school clubs. And in fact, we put
our club in place to offer an alternative
against Evangel and an evangelical club that is
explicitly designed to convert children and get
them to proselytize to other kids. So if parents
don't want to send their kids to an after school
Satan club, they can send them to an evangelical
club. There's other religious clubs. Really? I
think the controversy just evades the issue as to
whether or not we're willing to allow government
functionaries at school boards or whatever to
simply shut down somebody who's religious liberty
or free speech because they don't like it.
Speaker 3: So you're kind of doing it to
tweak the system. I get it. What are these
tenets of Satanism? Can you enlighten me?
Speaker 4: Yeah. I think the tenants are very
pro social, they're almost universal I would
think. And I think as time goes on, we'll kind of
converge on a consensus morality. But as. But we
don't have to. I mean, people we're not looking
to convert people into Satanism. We're not even
teaching children about Satanism.
Speaker 3: Well, give me a tenet.
Speaker 4: One should strive to
act with compassion and empathy
with it to all creatures within reason.
Speaker 3: Oh, that sounds fine. All
right, you might like it. Maybe. I don't know
about all that. Are you married, by the way?
Speaker 4: No, I'm not. Oh.
Speaker 3: Okay. I'm just. I was
just wondering. All right, so you're
probably going to go to hell, right?
Speaker 4: I don't believe in
hell. We're not theistic religious.
Speaker 3: All right. I thought maybe you
wanted to go to hell. What do I know? I
need to learn more about a better.
Speaker 4: Party than heaven. And.
Speaker 1: Fox News promoted this as a grilling
of Lucian Graves that Jesse Waters really grilled
him. The one substantive point that came up,
which is Lucian explaining how others should
be treated based on the Satanic Temples view
Jesse agreed with and then he switched to,
Are you married? I guess to just ridicule him. And
based on I don't even know and say no, of course
you couldn't find a wife or husband who knows?
Speaker 4: You know, I mean, you have one place
where all the sex was kind of go after
they live somewhere around interesting
life food. How might that might be okay.
Speaker 3: All right. We got to go.
I'm probably going to butcher
your name again. Lucien.
Speaker 4: Lucien Fish and.
Speaker 3: Green Revolution almost
had it. Thank you very much. Have a great night.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Fox News promotes that as a
grilling. And really, the interesting thing here
is every time that this satanic temple stuff comes
up and again, my view is I'm not a satanic temple
member and I'm not Christian, but I don't really
see any difference. And the condescension
from. And that there's many Christians that
have interviewed Lucian. The condescension about
your religion. It's it's nothing like ours. Like
our our thing is real. Your thing isn't real.
It's either evil or it's a parody and a joke,
substantively speaking. And it very
importantly in the eyes of the law
and this applies to after school programs as
well. There really is not a distinction. Now,
I do think that where you would start to go
over a line is if there is a religious group
and they want to have an after school program
and they're like openly advocating for violence
or murder. And by the way, I mean, what's crazy
is there are evangelical churches recently that
have advocated for violence against people who
support, for example, abortion being legal. So
like it actually happens and they don't get
in trouble. But if things were sensible,
I could see arguing that a particular religion
maybe shouldn't be allowed to have an after
school group if it could be proven that they're
really just advocating for physical violence and
they're teaching kids to, you know, go out
and attack people or something like that.
Beyond that, to pass these moral judgments or
to create tiers of religion based solely on the
number of followers that they have, and certainly
there are more Christians than Satanic Temple
members really misses the point of the framework
of how this country is organized. And Jesse Waters
and people like him seem to, from a starting
point, assume that, of course, Christianity is in
a different category than the satanic temple when
it really is. And and so Fox News promoted that as
a grilling. I didn't see much of a grilling. Let
me know your thoughts. Make sure you subscribe
to our YouTube channel. There are more than 3
million of you who watch our clips but don't
subscribe. My request is hit that subscribe
button. It's free and it really helps us.